>> Hi, YouTube. Umm, so I don't really have
a genius idea but I
think I have two suggestions that -- of what
we need in this world.
One is a new humanistic vision that is not
built around a nationality
an ethnicity, but rather around humanity.
Umm, something that doesn't exclude anyone
or any group but really is
built around our universal characteristics
that's share -- that --
that we hold in common.
The second is that I think we need to change
our view, uh, that we are
really, uh, have to think about how we build
a better world for the
next generation, one that's better than the
one that was given to us
and it seems that in the short one world we
often think what we can
get out of this world rather than making sure
that we are passing on
something better than what we are inherited.
That's it.